we have this uh story from the guardian
which um i respect i respect this story
no doomsday bunker not a single gun if
the us really is heading for civil war
i'm stuffed says arua madawi the super
rich are preparing to ride at the
apocalypse by their underground swimming
pools ordinary americans have bought
another 20 million firearms and me i
have a broom and a butter knife
i i have tremendous respect for her
recognizing everyone else is going on
buying guns and she won't the best part
is when she says she'll last a week she
says how long do you think you would
survive if everything went to hell civil
war erupted institutions crumbled and
there was absolutely nowhere safe in the
world left to run me i give myself one
week maybe two maybe two that's generous
lady
i would like to think that i'm a tough
survivor type the last time i went
camping i forgot to bring a sleeping bag
and sob myself to sleep so on balance i
would have to admit that i'm not i did
have a brief period this year when in a
fit of madness i thought i'd take up
urban farming and become as
self-sufficient as possible with a scrap
of garden in philadelphia that seemed to
go well until i proudly sent my mom a
photo of the luscious berry bushes i had
cultivated and she informed me that they
were poisonous weeds and i should get
rid of them immediately so yeah i don't
give myself great odds on surviving the
apocalypse uh
i respect that i i i actually respect
that
yeah yeah but look i don't want this
lady to get hurt i don't want her i want
her to survive i want her to
understand and maybe this is the first
step in realizing that the world is not
some fancy beautiful skittle and rainbow
bubble where you can go around and do
whatever the hell you want that there
are real dangers and we are kept safe by
a military and policing absolutely
something of being not maybe not
attacked by a wild animal i'm not
encouraging that anyone gets attacked by
wild animal when an animal comes at you
like i'm watching videos of like a wild
boar attacking someone you realize this
world wants you dead everything about
the universe is out there nature is
metal space will kill you if you go out
there too far you say the universe wants
you yes it wants to explode you in its
vacuum if you get near it
we're all against a mountain of of
terror and but we've lost that
realization being in these cities all
compacted it was canada right the wild
boar thing i didn't know where it was
from it was somewhere where they're only
allowed where they're only allowed to
have three rounds or something italy
yeah and the boar comes at him it's like
a is it a guy or it was a high voice i
thought it was a woman but i and you see
the boom miss boom miss point blank miss
and then you start beating with the gun
it's like well now people ask why do you
need 30 rounds because that boar would
not have been a threat to the individual
and boris can destroy you i'm very
likely i grew up hog hunting so i know
the dangers of of wild boar especially
even bar hawks down in the state of
florida and i mean you can get bore hogs
down there that are 300 400 pounds you
know four and a half six inch tush and
you know they basically i saw where you
know people would blood out because
they'll essentially grab them right
between you know kind of the crotch and
sever the femoral artery and i mean you
know you're stuck in the woods sitting
there bleeding out behind the pines and
palmettos so
it's a real risk one of the funniest
things i remember was when i had a
friend who went i think was in arizona
and they told me that they were locked
down and i was like whoa what's going on
they're like javelina spotting and i was
like what and they're like javelin i'm
like what is that and they sent me a
picture of this little pig and i was
like
i was like that that's why everyone's
forced inside and it's like yeah those
things will destroy them like they're
how big are they like the little wild
pigs out there in the desert or
something like that
dude
at the at at least those kids in college
understood
like those little wild pigs or whatever
they are is that they're called javelin
am i pronouncing it right i honestly
i've never heard of never heard of those
little pigs
i've got a lot of compassion for animals
and humans being part of that animal
kingdom but like when i had a raccoon
peccary i went near a raccoon and i was
like okay i'm gonna use my magic on this
thing and be kind with the raccoon it
was in a cage but it screamed like it
wanted to kill me and i realized i gotta
the viciousness in me came out i was
like uh that thing can die yeah i will
eradicate all raccoons if that's a
danger to my survival peccary is that
yeah
i know right that thing would probably
bite you and give you rabies or who
knows what you see that video of the
lady getting attacked by the fox yeah
yeah yes
so i just want to say you know we've
done a bunch of discussions over the
years
talking about
you know would liberals survive the
apocalypse and it's funny when i hear
people try and make the argument that
it's not the case that liberals wouldn't
survive and i'm like dude the people in
cities would be eating each other in
like a week she says she'd last a week
maybe too dude when there's no water
what do you think people are going to do
yeah it's like
ocean water for sure some people will
they'll drink the river water and then
die faster yeah it'll be quick yeah wow
man water man they said water the new
gold dysentery and all the other things
not understanding how to boil water not
understanding how to you know check
things i mean yeah look i i don't care
how many survival shows you try to watch
and you know the last frontier or alone
i mean at the end of the day if you
don't have proper survival skills you
don't have them yeah boiling water will
kill microbes but it doesn't get rid of
like a lot of stuff and it's very hard
boil water if there's no natural gas or
there's no
your stove doesn't work do these people
know how to make a fire and you know
maintain a fire yeah do they have any
idea how to start a fire without well
i'll just get a lighter go to the cvs
there is no cvs do you know how to hide
a fire from people that want your flight
this is where people you start asking so
have you ever built a friction fire do
you understand you know how to build
fires in different elevations and in
different climates and how to maintain
that and how to transfer because you
know you can't just build a fire and
think that you're going to live in one
place forever maybe you're having a
transporter fire how do you do that how
do you tender how do you i i would love
to i would really love to see some of
these people who have grown up in these
downtown you know metropolitan areas
where they've just always had something
at the tip of their finger
live for a week or even two as she said
oh my gosh if their uber each driver is
five minutes late they get zero stars
and they said
raging instagram like this is absurd and
they want you know like you think what
you build a fire imagine
the people i grew up in the south so for
us it was like my grandfather taught us
to live in the woods so the people who
think words are violence
they'll be out in the streets
in an apocalyptic scenario and there's
going to be some dude with a gun who's
hungry
and he's gonna he's
these people probably many of them won't
get to encounter words at all but how
will they respond to someone actually
grabbing them yeah just like fall to the
ground how many of them will yell for
the police
if seeing ben shapiro in the concert
hall made you like literally shake with
fear get ready when it's a bear right
and you don't have you have no idea how
to use a gun like maybe you have a gun
do you have any idea how to load it how
to fire the apocalypse happens the
cities are wiped out and ben shapiro's
already created a small working city
and then the liberals are outside the
walls screaming how terrified they are
of him and they're telling stories
they're you know it's like and then the
people who aren't insane will just knock
on the door and be like good sir i'm
looking for a job and food it's like we
are in need of someone of your specialty
come on in and they're outside screaming
terrified of ben shapiro
but so it's what i was saying earlier i
was like look i'm not i'm not going to
pretend like i think i would survive
um for one i'm out of the city in the
middle of nowhere and i've started
learning and uh and and
you know setting myself up in a way that
i would last longer than two weeks we
have emergency food we have bug out
locations we've got solar stuff
and uh i've been reading a bit obviously
we have the chickens but i'm not going
to pretend that i'd be better off than
the average say trump supporter who just
grew up in the country they know what
food they can already eat outside like
the first we have the pawpaw out here
the the hillbilly banana they call it
i didn't even know where it was last
year i'm like i see these little paw
paws i'm like looks like there's three
of them then papa season hit and there's
50 000 of them everywhere like on the
ground lit and i'm like there's just
food for days and i had no idea and the
people out here were laughing because
they're like we know all about it what
you can where the berries are what kind
of berries you eat because they grew up
around it and i didn't so here's my
question for you guys
how long do you think you'd last let's
say society breaks down right now we can
you know this this liberal lady she's
self-aware but what do you think corey i
mean i think i could sustain fine on
just my own survival skills and the fact
that i have sustainable food i have you
know the ability to go ahead and have my
own water sources and not to mention
that i own a 2 000 acre facility that's
well armed so if i really needed to when
it comes down to survival in the fittest
i'll take what i need yeah that's that's
kind of the point it's like
it's not even necessarily about what you
know but it's about what you currently
have yeah you know i mean so i have
currency and currency is not money
that's what people have to understand
currency is things like ammunition
currency is things like food first for
trade currency is things like whiskey or
you know people have to understand that
in a society where currency as far as
you know it has changed
now it becomes who is the most you know
the largest survival or the largest you
know kind of provider and store of goods
i mean this is why she talks about the
doomsday bunkers and the preppers you
know people make fun of preppers but i
can tell you right now that during the
unconstitutional lockdowns our family
never did without it's not just that
preppers are having fun yeah you know
what i watch these videos about preppers
and they always try to show you the
craziest guy who's like the waters are
coming so i got beans like that's that's
not real the real videos are really
great where it's a guy like oh yeah we
have here's where we store emergency
food we've got the animals over there
here's where it's basically homesteading
and we have like a you know long storage
and they're having a good time it's
purpose they have purpose
they're doing what they love they enjoy
like we have the chickens the chickens
are fun what concerns me is when
people's purpose becomes defending
against an apocalypse because then it's
almost like they need the apocalypse in
order to fulfill their purpose i don't
want to take it that far
let me let me ask
if you were in a city let's say you're
on a business trip in new york you're in
manhattan right in the middle and then
all of a sudden just
everything just goes off
you'd you would still be completely fine
and that's that's kind of the point
right well yeah because my initial
instinct wouldn't be to sustain myself
in that city it would be to get back to
where i have all my supplies and and all
my sustainability for sure but i just
mean like
basic combat skills yeah i mean like i'm
i'm gonna you know it's not like we sit
in a you know kind of empty solitude you
know building that has no food
whatsoever i mean you have enough to
sustain you for a number of days clearly
my big thing would be pack what i can
get out get my way a means of
transportation and get to where i have
the most sustainability which is my own
facility the funny thing is so many of
these liberals would be like they'd go
outside and be like okay everybody let's
talk about what our plan is and they
just sit around it's like you realize
there's no water in this place the water
pressure is gone there's no water it
would be a lot no conversation looking
for who to serve well i i think for a
while you just have an increase in
criminality right so you just have the
stealing and looting of basic goods or
essentially the 2020 mostly
uh what is it
peaceful
yeah
i mean you'd essentially just have that
you'd have rampant increase in
criminality you'd have a lot of theft
you'd have murders you'd have all these
different things going on but eventually
when those supplies run out
and there is no workforce and no one is
actually reproducing anything
then you'd have to go into true survival
skills as well
i like what you said about currency
because i did a thread the other day on
on social about the coming great
depression which i think is is
inevitable assuming the government
doesn't collapse right assuming i'm not
talking apocalypse i'm just talking
about like like the great depression of
our of our grandparents of old um and i
like what you said about currency
because i was telling people to start
keeping big supplies of
cash because the black markets will pop
up everywhere and people like not
necessarily 10 but people liked him who
have extra chickens will create a black
market for eggs because we're in a great
depression cash won't be the currency
though that's the whole thing well if
the government has gold billions and
it'll have to be things like fuel but my
my point was it could be but my point
was that though that they're not going
to take your credit card you're not
going to take 100 percent they're not
going to take a check they're not going
to part they're not going to take your
gold yeah no they're going to need
something that they can easily change
that's assuming the government hasn't
collapsed which i don't think it's going
to i don't think we're headed towards
towards an apocalypse i do think we're
headed towards a depression though it's
not just that it's that even if the us
collapsed other governments would have
to clap collapse for for something like
gold to lose its value yeah right in the
event that the u.s goes into chaos in
their civil war there's still going to
be people who say hey that gold is
valuable in turkey that gold is valuable
in europe so i will take it from you and
bring it there there's there's still
going to be trade going on
i just think that
in the event of a real civil war people
need to understand is that it's not
these regular liberal types this is what
i hear a lot from people they're like ah
i think it was bill um bill burr he's
the comedian right right now
he was saying something recently on tr i
think he was on trigonometry and it
shows you the danger of ignorance he's a
funny guy he's a good actor i respect
his his work but not his political
positions because
you know he said on joe rogan he's like
look joe i just put on the the tv tell
me to wear a mask i wear it or i don't
what two weeks later i'll turn it on
i'll do what they tell me that's the
kind of attitude where he says
right he's not on this on on
trigonometry regular people don't care
about this stuff you go out and nobody's
talking about it and that's that's
that's ignorance of history if i go out
i went i went down to like strasbourg
and front royal the other day yeah i'm
in maga country of course no one's
fighting each other they all live next
to each other and have the same politics
you go into a city it's it's woke
country everybody's got the flags of
course no one's fighting each i mean
they're still fighting each other to be
honest but not always because they're
next to each other it's the geographical
differences where people are spreading
apart from each other
and what happens is in any major
conflict it is a small minority of the
people who are
leading the fighting and when you have
the president uh donald trump just
called joe biden enemy of the state joe
biden called trump supporters extremists
and then tried walking it back later and
then doubled down and said you know the
funny thing is when he says maga
republicans are a threat and so are
there policies you know you know he's
talking about trump supporters because
they're the ones who are pushing those
policies and supporting those people you
have the highest levels of government
there is a conflict happening it doesn't
matter what regular people are thinking
are doing it's that law enforcement
the the the military apparatus are
currently being pointed at each other
sooner or later you get what met tybee
calls that arrest this man moment where
the cars rush to the police station two
guys jump out and point arrest that man
at each other and then the police
basically decide whose side are they on
that's when you figure out who's
fighting who thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there